una de las sospechas que plantea el
reporte es que 39 de las 49 muertes
fueron heridas de bala y que no se ha
identificado a ningún manifestante
portando armas significa esto
directamente que esas muertes pueden
haber sido provocadas por la policía Y
qué dice el gobierno al respecto Hola
Rodrigo Muchas gracias por tenerme aquí
como buen decís de las 49 nosotros
identificamos que al menos 39 serían por
heridas de bala y de esas 39 34
identificamos a través de las autopsias
de las pericias balísticas que fueron
direccionadas hacia la cabeza el torso o
la espalda lo cual en contacto con
expertos forenses nos dicen que esos
ataques pueden parecer direccionados
Esto es algo que es importante porque
también muestra que esas muertes podrían
constituir ejecuciones extrajudiciales o
arbitrarias y de acuerdo con el derecho
internacional de esas muertes el estado
es responsable nosotros lo que estamos
pidiendo Es que la fiscal de la nación
investigue no solo a quienes gatillaron
sino también a altos mandos pueden haber
ordenado que se lleven a cabo esos
abusos o que sabiendo de la situación no
hicieron nada para detenerlos o para
garantizar la rendición de cuentas y que
estos abusos no queden en la impunidad
como si han quedado impunes abusos en el
Perú en el pasado bueno la presidenta
boluarte ha dicho hoy que ustedes son
solo una ong que las muertes están
investigando se tiene información sobre
cómo avanzan estas investigaciones
Nosotros hemos detectado graves
deficiencias en las investigaciones
llevadas a cabo por la fiscalía por
ejemplo en dos casos los cuerpos de las
víctimas se enterraron sin que se
realicen las autopsias en varios casos
los fiscales no llevaron a cabo la
recogida de pruebas iniciales clave que
tienen que hacerse en las primeras horas
y que luego pueden comprometer toda la
investigación nuestro informe se basa en
más de 140 entrevistas más de 37 horas
de vídeo verificadas más de 600
fotografías informe de balística
autopsias registros médicos expedientes
penales somos una ong somos una
organización independiente de que
analiza en base al derecho y nuestro
informe se basa en toda esta evidencia
Por lo cual consideramos que es
importante que el gobierno la fiscalía
los distintos actores lo tengan en
cuenta
y de confirmarse Finalmente la
culpabilidad de las fuerzas de seguridad
y una hipotética connivencia del
gobierno Qué consecuencias podría haber
para el ejecutivo
respeten toda garantía debido proceso
sean contra los agentes o sea contra la
presidenta el Primer Ministro y luego se
deben definir Cuáles son las las penas
que se aplican lo importante acá es que
que haya justicia que esto no quede en
el olvido y más allá de los nombres
propios que luego terminen siendo
condenados que que haya condenas esto no
no puede volver porque también es un
mensaje hacia el futuro hacia las
propias policías hacia los propios
militares que si ven que esto queda en
la impunidad Ellos tienen un cheque en
blanco para actuar ante cada protesta y
vulnerar el derecho a la protesta
pacífica de las personas en el Perú